. Please, I want you.
I'm leaving today. Ah, nee, it's too schwierig, I think. I think it's part of it. It seems today somebody. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu Das Podcast Usu. Endlich mal wieder eine neue Folge. So lange hat es gedauert, wir haben keine Pfingstauszeit genommen, und ihr hört ihn schon natürlich, er kann sich nicht zurückhalten. The Master of Stefan Titze. Titzel. Ich bin da, Titzel, hallo. Es freut mich sehr, heute mit Blontien Will, meinem Co-Moderator Gastgeber, dieser schönen 21. Folge zu sagen. Das war eine Pfingstpause, oder? Das war... Was war das geil? Wie hast du Pfingst verwandt? Ich habe gefeiert, das ist mein Lieblingsverhältnis. Ich habe, glaube ich, nicht geschlafen das gesamte Wochenende durch. Ich habe gegeben, was ging. Aber wir sind auch richtige Pfingstfreaks, sind wir auch. Ich bin ganz müde davon jetzt. Ich habe den ganzen Tag meine Pfingstsongs, meine Lieblingspfingstsongs gebrüllt und bin durch die Wohnung gelaufen. Für mich ist die schlimmste Nachricht, dass ich wieder ein Jahr lang warten muss bis Pfingsten, ehrlich gesagt. Ich fand auch gut, deinen Tweet, wo du dich einerseits entschuldigt hast, dass keine Folge kommt, andererseits aber einen Hauch von Interaktivität reinbringen wolltest, indem du gefragt hast, ja, wo feiert ihr denn Pfingsten? Null Antwort, nichts passiert. Die Leute haben den Gag verstanden. Niemand fragt danach, wie man Pfingsten verbracht hat, weil das Pfingsten einfach der most random Feiertag, den es gibt überhaupt. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Leute den Gang verstanden haben oder einfach nur nicht antworten generell. Aber da muss man gerade sagen, wenn wir gerade bei Communityarbeit sind, vielen, vielen Dank für die ganzen coolen Zuschriften, vor allem hat uns natürlich gefreut, Maria hat uns ein Foto geschickt von der Booster-Gang. Mega geil. Unglaublich geil. Sind das alles Leute, die uns hören oder hast du die einfach dazu gezwungen, so ein Booster-Ding, da sind das Passanten, die du in Booster einheimst. Ich habe mit Photoshop ein bisschen nachgeholfen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Also wenn du das noch beantworten könntest, wir waren sehr stolz, wir haben einen kurzen Hohenflug. Das stimmt schon. Man muss mal zusammenfassen, also dieses Bild beweist, wir haben sehr viele, sehr junge und sehr gut aussehende Hörer, und ich meine, welche bessere Nachricht gibt es denn als das? Natürlich mal wieder die ernüchternde Botschaft, dass unsere Zuhörer wesentlich cooler sind als wir, aber naja, zu viele Freunde habe ich nicht, wie auf dem Bild, ehrlich gesagt. Aber wir sind echt ganz schön, also von euch kommt sehr viel, muss man sagen. Auch von uns kommt sehr wenig. Und von uns kommt sehr wenig. Ich selber wurde vom Podcast-Ufo bei Skype noch nicht angenommen. Also wenn ihr, wenn ihr, wo ich wurde, dann, oh, warum haben die mich noch nicht angenommen? Ich selber, ich habe dem Podcast-Ufo auch schon eine Anfrage geschickt bei Skype, ich selber wurde noch nicht bestätigt als Freund. Und deswegen kann ich auch selber, obwohl ich selber Teil davon bin, kann ich selber nicht anrufen und irgendwelche Nachrichten verlassen. Das ist echt scheiße. Aber allerseits, es war Pfingsten und ich mal. Wenn das keine Ausrede ist, hey, es war fucking Pfingsten. Apropos, unser Thema kommt heute auch von einem Gast, von einem Zuhörer. Nein. Doch, in der Tat. Ich muss kurz raussuchen. Ja, vielen Dank dafür. Da sind uns immer so tolle Themenvorschläge geschickt, anscheinend, und wir die anscheinend auch annehmen und intern klären, dass wir das so machen.
Gut, dass das so der Fall ist, wie wir uns das so gut abgetan haben.
Und zwar Severin Schwalb hat geschrieben, alter Sevi, du alte Ratte, du geile Sau, du! Themenvorschlag, Schlaf und Träume, finde ich gut. Ja, geil, richtig geil, richtig geil, können wir machen. Ich habe tatsächlich die letzte Woche relativ wenig geschlafen.
Ich war auf einer teuflischen Odyssee zwischen Köln, Berlin und den Niederhölln begleitet mit einer sanften Melodie von streikenden Bahnführern. Das war echt nicht so ganz cool. Florentin singt den Bahnführer-Blues. Aber es war auch okay. Ja, war tatsächlich so. Ich dachte, ich bin total clever. Und die meisten Katastrophengeschichten beginnen so, auch so der Zweite Weltkrieg. Was ist schief gelaufen? Folgendes, ich dachte, ich bin total clever, ja, und die meisten Katastrophengeschichten beginnen so, auch so der Zweite Weltkrieg, so, was ist schief gelaufen, folgendes, ich dachte, ich bin total... Und greif Poland an. Greif Russland an. Ha, damit rechnen die nie, aber dann, naja, der Rest ist Geschichte, wortwörtlich. Und zwar begann der Streit ja um zwei Uhr morgens, und ich dachte, ja, Leute, dann bin ich total clever und fahre halt mit dem Zug um null Uhr dreißig, also vor zwei Uhr. Auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof habe ich mir dann einiges überlegt, also wie läuft es, fahren die dann nur eineinhalb Stunden lang und schmeissen mich dann einfach raus irgendwo auf der Bahnsteige und müssen da stehen bleiben? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Du stellst wahnsinnig viele blöde Fragen, aber das war eine sehr gute Frage, wo man sich manchmal echt fragen muss, wie das läuft. Ja, und ich dachte, dass dann einfach auf dem Zug anfangen zu streiken und der Zug halt noch so dahin rollt vielleicht.
Ausrollt, du sagst Köln ausrollt.
Hatte ich jetzt gehofft tatsächlich, war jetzt meine grosse Hoffnung.
War aber nicht der Fall, nein, Zug fiel einfach aus.
Einfach random, ach nee, scheiß drauf, wir haben zwar angekündigt, Spiegel Online hat geschrieben, zwei Uhr nachts, aber fuck it. Das ist einfach eine Lüge, also darfst du einfach nicht, du kannst einfach sagen, wir fahren ab dem So und so viel nicht mehr, aber eine Uhrzeit zu nennen ist doch völliger Quatsch, weil es fahren ja nicht alle Züge um zwei Uhr los. Da ist der Punkt, wo ich wirklich wütend werde. Ich meine, die sollen streiken, von mir aus ist zwar scheiße und nervt mich, aber es ist ihr gutes Recht. Aber wenn sie dann sagen, wir streiken ab zwei Uhr. Mach das mal kurz vor, also wie muss man sich vorstellen, wenn du wütend bist, ganz doll. Da werde ich richtig fuchsig, das kann doch so nicht wahr sein am bahn so stand ich da am bahnhof und sagt leute eine ich meine wenn ihr sagt ihr streikt ist die eine sache aber wenn ihr sagt ihr streikt ab zwei und um 0.30 stehe ich hier mit einem abgesagten zug so geht es nicht so haben wir nicht gepokert meine herren und da saßen tatsächlich die ganze nacht durch irgendwie so drei drei mit fünfziger fette Männer, die auch so Warnwesten anhatten und saßen da rum so neben dem Wir-Streiken-Schild.
Und man weiß nicht genau, wer das war. Waren das jetzt streikende Bahnschaffner oder nicht oder waren das einfach Leute von der Bahn, die da versucht haben, das zu geregeln?
Auf jeden Fall haben die den gesamten Hass abbekommen von allen Leuten, die da gestrandet sind.
Und immer, wenn Leute vorbeigegangen haben, sagen, ja, fickt euch ihr Penner, fickt euch ihr Scheiss. So leise Fluren vorbeigelaufen. Aber wahrscheinlich hatten die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun und haben sich einfach zur Sicherheit nur Warnwesten angezogen und haben den ganzen Hass abbekommen. Und auch meinen Hass natürlich, weil ich habe denen einige böse Blicke zugegeben. Das ist genauso wie die Bauarbeiter auf Autobahnen zum Beispiel, wo man sich dann immer sehr, sehr aufregt, wenn man dann immer zwei Stunden steht, weil einfach so eine Baustelle gerade ist, die seit zwölf Jahren die A1 komplett blockiert. Und dann, glaube ich, kriegen auch Bauarbeiter, da gab es mal so einen Bericht im Fernsehen, kriegen die das ab. Also Bauarbeiter werden einfach gehatet. Autofahrer zeigen dann Mittelfinger und beschimpfen die dann einfach. Wobei, das sind die wenigstens können, die führen das einfach nur aus, ihren Auftrag. Oder wenn ein Unfall ist irgendwie und die halbtote Leiche davon getragen wird, kriegt die auch nochmal, fick dich! Was musst du dir einen scheiß Unfall bauen? Also die Leute sind schon immer sehr... Ja, das Leiche ist dann sehr sauer noch. Genau, das Leiche ist auch sauer. Fuck! Scheiß! Auf jeden Fall hat das dazu geführt, dass ich wieder traurig nach Hause getrottet bin, noch mal vier Stunden geschlafen habe dann nochmal zum Bahnhof gegangen bin und dann mit so den Ersatzzügen gefahren bin. Denn abschließend muss man sagen, der Streik ist gar nicht so schlimm. Es fahren ja Ersatzzüge so. Also so ist es ja nicht. Ich glaube, Streiks sind so lange nicht so schlimm, wie man sich plötzlich anfängt, irgendwelche Pläne auszudenken, wo man denkt, wow, ich bin so geil, ich habe dieses System durchschaut und überlistet, das Streiksystem ich habe, ab dann wird es scheiße. Ja, vor allem, wenn man sich so ein System ausdenkt, ab dann wird es scheiße. Ich habe versucht, das System zu überlisten, bin gescheitert und habe dann gemerkt, dass ich es gar nicht hätte überlisten müssen. Ja, genau. Also das ist so der klassische, ich glaube, die klassischen drei Stufen des klassischen mythologischen Helden, ja, Herkules auch, denkt sich über Strategie aus, Scheitern und am Ende so, ach nee, die Tür war die ganze Zeit ja offen ja offen. Das ist, glaube ich, genau, ich habe genau diesen Heldenmythos durchgemacht am Wochenende.
Aber du sagst, du hast nicht geschlafen, weil du halt unterwegs warst, aber schläfst du normalerweise in der Bahn?
Ich versuche immer in der Bahn zu schlafen, aber es ist extrem schwierig.
Kann man das? Träumt man da?
Nicht wirklich, da träumt man tatsächlich sehr schlecht und man kann Traum von Realität kaum auseinanderhalten.
Und letztens, ich hatte mal, das wollte ich schon ewig erzählen, weil ich das so lustig fand,
ich hatte ja teilweise, bin ich nach Köln gefahren, um auch einen Podcast mit dir aufzunehmen und hatte dann mein Mikrofon und ein Kabel dabei. Und also dieses, also um das jetzt mal für die technisch weniger bewandten Leute zu erklären, also wir nehmen mit auf mit einem Mikrofon und in dem steckt ein Kabel, da kommen dann die ganzen Wörter und die Satzzeichen, die Grammatik, die fliegen dann da rum, kommen manchmal ein bisschen durcheinander. Das ist wie eine kleine Strasse, wie so ein Weg, da laufen die entlang, ganz flott sind die unterwegs, ihren Familien und dann gehen sie mal zum Kabelzoo oder gehen mal in so ein Kabel-Minigolf-Spielen auf dem Weg. Und dann laufen sie durch das Kabel in ein Audiointerface und von da aus dann in den Computer und da wird das dann aufgezeichnet. Und mein Kabel ist extrem lang. Das ist also viel, viel, viel zu lang. Das ist glaube ich fünf Meter lang für eine 30 Zentimeter Strecke. Also es ist unglaublich lang. Ich frage mich auch immer, wie solche Gerätekabellängen festgelegt werden. Wer legt das fest? Nein, nein, du legst sie fest. Du bist der einzige, der festgelegt. Nein, nein, nein. Es gibt tausende Längen und du kannst wählen, was du brauchst. Es gibt oft schon Abstückgeln. Man braucht 30 cm bei dem, was wir machen. Ja, aber ich habe einen 5-Meter-Kabel. Ja, aber das liegt doch an dir. War vielleicht auch ein Fehlkauf. Ja, aber trotzdem. Ja, ich habe zum Beispiel auch eine Maus, die hat wirklich ohne Witz ein 2 m langes Kabel. Eine Maus, wo die Idee ist, dass es direkt neben dem Computer ist. Warum muss es so lang sein? Wiederum hatte ich mal einen Föhn mit einem bestimmt
vier Zentimeter langen Kabel, wo man dann
irgendwie immer in der Wand hängt und versucht, sich irgendwie
zu föhnen. Ja, genau. Wie Kopfhörer.
Kopfhörerkabel ist nicht so schwer.
Menschen sind, sagen wir mal, von
1,30 Kinder bis,
also Kopfhörende Kinder, Kopfhörer
hörende Kinder bis, sagen wir mal,
zwei Meter zehn gross.
Und es ist nicht so schwierig, da zwischen eine Kabellänge zu finden, die den meisten Menschen passt. Aber ich habe schon so offen Kabel gehabt, was einfach bis zu meinem Bauch ging und dann hing das Handy da rum, was nicht so ganz so clever ist. Ja, auch meine Kopfhörer tatsächlich sind auch extrem lang. Also ich kann mich, ist zwar ganz gut, weil ich mich auf meinem Bürorollstuhl durch mein ganzes Zimmer rollen kann, ohne die Kopfhörer abnehmen zu müssen, aber an sich weiß ich auch nicht, ob das das so eine gute Idee ist. Naja, um das mal zu Ende zu bringen, ich habe ein wahnsinnig langes Kabel und bei mir war es ja so, vielleicht habe ich das auch schon erzählt, nee, genau, jetzt weiss ich nicht wieder, wie es war. In der letzten Folge habe ich nämlich die Folge, habe ich die Anekdote angefangen mit Ich fahre in der Bahn und du hast mich wüst unterbrochen und einfach irgendwo anders hingeleitet. Und ich habe mir die ganze Zeit gedacht, warum müssen wir das nicht auf... Nee, das war Universum, das war Folge 20, mein Lieber. Kannst du nochmal reinschauen? So, nochmal, um das immer ganz angerissen zu haben. Auf jeden Fall hatte ich dann dieses fünf Meter lange Kabel im Zug dabei und ich habe früher immer, als es noch kälter war, hatte ich meine Jacke dabei und habe die dann so über mein Gesicht gelegt, damit ich nichts mehr sehe, damit ich besser schlafen kann. Jetzt ist es aber wärmer geworden, ich habe die Jacke nicht mehr dabei und dachte mir, oh fuck, daran habe ich ja gar nicht gedacht. Und jetzt hatte ich nichts dabei. Dann habe ich das letzte Mal gesagt, ja, nimm doch die Kapuze. Dann meinte ich, Kapuze sind aber nicht lang genug. Dann hast du gesagt, wie viel Dreck wahrscheinlich immer eine Kapuze ist, dann habe ich gesagt, die Kapuze ist der Bauchnabel. Und schon warme bei deinem braunen Pullo. Genau, ja, da sind wir abgewogen, genau. Und jetzt nehmen wir aber mal die andere, die richtige Ausfahrt und erzählen meine Anekdote zu Ende. Ausstieg in Fahrtrichtung Spaß. Ja, und zwar habe ich dann in meinem Rucksack gesucht, was ich denn mir ins Gesicht legen könnte, um Licht abzuhalten, und ich habe wirklich nichts Besseres gefunden als das fünf Meter lange XLR-Kabel. Das heißt, ich lag auf diesem komplett horizontale Stimmung gefahrenen Stuhl im ICE und hatte wirklich so Kabelsalat einfach auf dem Gesicht. Ich denke ja bei jeder Gelegenheit, komm, wir müssen endlich mal Podcast-UFO-Flyer machen, die du dann immer verteilst oder in coolen Anlässen oder so, oder Sticker oder dass wir T-Shirts haben, wo wir mit uns immer rumlaufen, dass man uns sehen kann. Aber wenn ich sowas dann höre, dann denke ich mir, bitte, niemand darf dich in der Öffentlichkeit mit dem Podcast in Verbindung bringen. Niemand. Ja, aber du musst verstehen, das ist immer so drei Uhr morgens, du hast nicht geschlafen, du bist komplett fertig, du hast gerade vier Pickups gegessen, weil du einfach irgendwie vergessen hast zu zählen am Automaten und du einfach in so eine Wiederholungsschleife gekommen bist, in so einen Zeitstrudel und einfach in den Automaten leer gekauft hast. Und dann sitzt du da vollkommen überzuckert, saumüde und denkst dir, fuck it einfach. Dann lag ich da mit diesen Kabeln auf meinem Gesicht und es war mir auch scheißegal, es war mir auch nicht unangenehm oder so. Im Nachhinein dachte ich mir so, machst du einen kompletten Schaden eigentlich? Aber auf jeden Fall, ich konnte auch nicht schlafen. Und mittlerweile habe ich mir so eine App geholt, weil ich habe immer so lange rumprobiert, was ich denn, also zum Thema Schlaf, also Schlafhilfen. Ich habe mir nämlich auch überlegt, was man denn da hören kann, zum Beispiel Musik, weil ich habe immer Kopfhörer drin, damit ich die Umgebungslautsteige nicht höre, dann kann ich ja auch gleich Musik hören. Dann habe ich so Entspannungsmusik gehört, ja bei Spotify gibt es ja so die Playlist Schlaf und so, ich weiß auch nicht genau, welche Musiker da für Schlafmusik schreiben, die da Bock drauf haben, aber gut,
warum nicht, gibt's auch.
Ich denke so, sag mal,
keine Ahnung, ACDC, das nächste Album
machen wir jetzt nur für Schlaf.
Das ist eine Riesenbranche
und ich hab echt Bock, vor allem die Konzerte,
die Konzerte, wenn du auf
Konzerten von Interpreten die
8 Stunden langes Konzert machen. Ja, sehr geil.
Kannst du auch schon einen Schlafsack mitbringen,
kannst dich vor der Bühne hinlegen. Ja, finde ich auch
gut, genau. Ja, oder zum Beispiel
Vielen Dank. Konzerten von Interpreten, die für die Pailies machen. Ja, acht Stunden langes Konzert, ja. Ja, sehr geil. Kannst du auch schon einen Schlafsack mitbringen, kannst dich vor der Bühne hinlegen. Ja, finde ich auch gut, genau. Ja, oder zum Beispiel, jetzt bin ich mal in den Bereich Geräusche hineingeglitten, also Ambient, Entspannungsgeräusche und habe mir da extra so eine App runtergeladen. Regenwald, Wale. Regenwald, Regen, Feuer, Wind, ja. Hölle, Höllensounds, Affengehege, so Strand, ne? Kindertagesstätte, die ganzen tollen Sounds. Ja, genau, Strand, wo alles gut ist, du hast die Wellen, den Sand und dann hast du... Und im Hintergrund hört man die Volleyballspieler, die Volleyballspieler, ne, drei zu zwei, nein, Paul, ich hab's schon drei zu drei. Hey Süße, willst du bei uns Volleyball mitspielen? Nein, lass mich in Ruhe. Nein, lass mich in Ruhe. Nein, lass mich in Ruhe. Melonne, melonne, melonne. Coco-Banana, Coco-Banana. Unser Gelato, per favore, Gelato. Kann ich dir den Rücken eincremen? Nein, lass mich in Ruhe. Lass mich in Ruhe. Geh weg, du perverse Schwein. Genau. Hey Süße, ich bin nicht deine Süße. Aber es war so realistische Ambien-Sounds, das fände ich total geil.
Ja, oder auch so im Wald, wo dann irgendwie
ab und zu eine Motorsäge gekommen ist, einfach den
halben Wald umholz. Ja, das ist ein Family-Gag.
Wirklich?
Ich schaue gar nicht so viel Family-Gag.
Wow, dann habe ich jetzt selber Family-Gag gemacht.
Ich schaue gar keinen Family-Gag.
Habe ich noch nie geguckt? Habe ich ja auch gerade gesagt.
Naja, du hast es ein bisschen...
Naja. Ich habe es ein bisschen anders formuliert.
Sorry. Entschuldigung, dass ich deine hohen Erwartungen
Vielen Dank. Ich schaue gar keinen Family Guy. Habe ich noch nie geguckt? Habe ich ja auch gerade gesagt. Naja, du hast es ein bisschen, na ja.
Ich habe es ein bisschen anders formuliert, sorry.
Entschuldigung, dass ich deine hohen Erwartungen nicht standhalten kann.
Naja, auf jeden Fall war es echt total gruselig.
Und ich habe das dann auch vor dem ICE im Bett ausprobiert.
Und da gibt es dann auch eine, also gewisse Soundquelsen kann ich gut nachvollziehen, also so beruhigende Dinge, ja, so Wald, Feuer, Strand, Lagerfeuer.
Aber dann gibt es auch immer noch eine Rubrik, die sich mir nicht erschließt und das ist unter Wasser. Und das ist dann so Walgesänge, Delfine, so Geblubber, wo ich mir denke, unter Wasser finde ich die im allerschlimmsten überhaupt keine Ruhe, da habe ich Todesangst und will damit nichts zu tun haben. Und ich finde gerade diese Wahlgesänge, das sagt man ja immer so, ich höre mir Wahlgesänge an zum Entspannen.
Hört euch mal wirklich Wahlgesänge an, das ist das fucking creepyste Zeug, was es überhaupt nur gibt.
Das klingen wie irgendwelche Alien. Hast du eine Vorstellung davon, wie Wahlgesänge klingen?
Nee, aber ich mach's mal kurz nach, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Wie der Wal an dir vorbeischwimmt. Sehr schön. Ja, genau so. Sehr schneller Wal. Ja, genau. Ja, Mark Wahlberg, auch dazu. Nicht so wichtig. Auf jeden Fall habe ich dann auch mal versucht, diese Unterwasserwelt und fand es furchtbar. Und habe es allerdings sein Technik, war die App irgendwie verbuggt, habe das nicht mehr ausbekommen. Ich habe es nicht mehr ausbekommen. Und ich habe andere Sachen dazu gemacht, ich konnte es aber nicht mehr ausschalten. Und auch wenn ich aus der App rausgehe, hatte ich immer noch diese Wahlgesänge und geblubber. Und ich war total irgendwie in Schockstarre. Und ich dachte mir, fuck it, weil es hat mich nicht mehr losgelassen, einfach. Also irgendwie ganz in der Ferne. Ich frage es auch mal wahnsinnig weit weg. Ja, das stimmt. Die sind Nina, war alles Nina.
Ich frage mich auch immer, also irgendwann glaube ich, ist es soweit, dann gibt es so viele Frequenzen, so viel Bluetooth-Zeug, so rumgerimotet, Wachsinn, dass man irgendwann sich aus Versehen so in die Lautsprecher der Bahn hackt, weil die einfach die Frequenzen, die gleiche Frequenz benutzen oder so. Und ich habe irgendwie die Angst, dass irgendwann mal, wenn man ein Wahlgesang oder hört, plötzlich das auf den Zug überspringt und im Zug plötzlich so Wahlgesänge laufen oder sowas. Das wäre wahnsinnig lustig, wenn so die eigene Playlist plötzlich alle hören. Ja, oder dass man auch gar keine Hörgeräte mehr braucht, sondern dass man einfach durch die Gegend läuft und jeder Mensch hat eine eigene Frequenz und dann kann man die Schallwellen so fein arretieren, dass nur noch eine Person es hört. Das wäre doch auch cool. Ja, und man kann selber einstellen, von wie man gar nichts mehr hören will, welche Frequenz man am besten komplett blockieren kann. Ja, das finde ich auch sehr. Es gibt übrigens, was ich total lustig von habe, habe ich jetzt gestern gehört, es gibt Kopfhörerdiscos, also leise Discos. Ah ja, genau. Also man hört, wo man einfach nur einen Kopfhörer auffert und dann darum eiert. Ich weiß nicht, was man in der Disco macht. Tanzen vielleicht. Tanzen, ja. Tanzen, das ist eine Kampfsportart. Tanzen, ja, Tanzen. Das ist, glaube ich, ganz schön crazy. Also hört dann da jeder ein anderes Lied oder hört jeder aber in der gleichen Schnelligkeit, sodass man halt trotzdem den gleichen Rhythmus tanzt. Aber vor allem, man kann sich ja gar nicht unterhalten. Tanzt da jeder für sich. Nee, aber das kann man ja in einer normalen Disco auch nicht. Ich habe gehört, man geht in eine Disco, um sich mit Frauen irgendwie ein bisschen abzugeben. Von daher kann man dann vielleicht immer so als cooler Move, ja, einfach mal so neutral wie möglich ausgedrückt, vielleicht kann man als cooler Move dann der anderen Person die Kopfhörer abnehmen, so, hey, ich will mit dir reden. Ich habe mal auf Galileo gesehen, so von wegen der Jugendratgeber, wie Eltern mit ihren Jugendlichen umgehen sollen und so ein bisschen die Jugendslang erklärt. Die Kopfhörer abnehmen und mit ihnen reden. Genau, und da hieß es, ja, es ist völlig normal für junge Leute, dass sie ununterbrochen Kopfhörer drin haben, und es ist auch normal unter Jugendlichen, dass wenn der eine mit dem anderen reden wird, will, dass er ihnen dann einfach den Kopfhörer rauszieht. Wo ich mir dachte, nope, das ist nicht der Fall. Aber so jung bin ich auch nicht mehr. Ja, es werden Erwachsene Erwachsene Tipps geben und irgendwie dabei die Gruppe vergessen. Ja, genau, furchtbar. Aber glaube ich, fände ich für mich ein ganz cooles Club-Erlebnis eigentlich. Und da kann auch jeder seine eigene Musik hören. Da ist dann Tanzen alle außerhalb des Rhythmus. Florentin will erzielt von seinen Lieblings-Club-Momenten. Wir sind alle gespannt, was es für eine lange Liste gibt. Träumen. Ja, also ich wollte, um die Anekdote zu Ende zu bringen, habe ich dann tatsächlich, bin ich auch irgendwann... Das ist auch sehr lange. Ich bin nach Pfingsten nicht mehr auffassungsfähig. Ja, Pfingsten war so flashy, irgendwie so kurzweilig. Ich bin tatsächlich dann auch eingeschlafen und habe dann auch von Unterwasserwelten geträumt. Nicht lange, weil ich aufgewacht bin, weil es eher ein Albtraum war. Aber ich wirklich dachte, ich bin unter Wasser und kann nicht mehr auftauchen. Und das war ganz, ganz furchtbar. Das war ganz schrecklich. Naja. Das war jetzt noch wichtig. Ja, um das abzuschließen, ist es für zu schauen, aber wichtig, dass man das abzuschließen. Ja, mein Gott, dann lass sie doch von vornherein so, wie sie war. Ich habe jetzt übrigens mal, mir ist auch gefallen, du benutzt noch nicht mal Anglizismen, du benutzt einfach sehr viele englische Worte. Also sehr viele englische Worte und ich mache, ab jetzt mache ich, nur um das mitzuteilen, eine Strichliste bei englischen Worte, die du benutzt. Und ich werde am Ende das Ergebnis mitteilen. Okay, dann mache ich auch eine Strichliste von dir, sag aber noch nicht, was es ist, damit du nicht beeinflusst. Schlechte Witze. Weiß ich nicht, ob ich da mitteilen kann. Kurze Spitze untergebracht, sehr gut. Übrigens ganz kurz, um jetzt mal den Rant-Teil noch abzuschließen. Was sind deine Lieblings-Sphinx-Songs eigentlich? Ja gut, da hätte man sich, sag sowas von vorne, da hätte man sich tolle Wortspiele raus. Last Pfingsten, I gave you my heart, but the very next day, you gave it away. Stairway to Pfingsten, auf jeden Fall bei mir ganz oben, Highway to Pfingsten. Last Pfingsten. Warte mal, irgendein Wortspiel muss uns noch einfallen. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte. Bing.
Bing.
Ingst, Angst, Fingst, Fingst, Jing, Fingis, Fingis Khan, Fing, Fingis Khan, Fing, Fingis Khan, hey Reiter, ho Reiter, hey Reiter, immer, ist uns ja gerade gleichzeitig Fingis Khan eingefallen.
Ja, ich glaube, durch die Versetzung, durch den Delay hat einer von uns gerade gemogelt, aber wir finden nicht heraus, wer, weil wir nicht genau wissen, wer hinterher ist.
Ja, ja,, durch die Versetzungen, durch den Delay hat einer von uns gerade gemogelt, aber wir finden nicht heraus, wer, weil wir nicht genau wissen, wer hinterher ist. Das Miesma, ja, ja. Pfingst. Aber gut, vielleicht fällt uns nicht ein, um nochmal ganz kurz den Rant abzuschliessen, ich will die Zuschauer immer so ein bisschen anfeuern, damit die so richtig innerlich brennen, damit die richtig wütend sind, damit die auch wirklich emotional bei uns dabei sind. Und zwar habe ich mir ein Hotel gebucht, als ich in Köln angekommen war, und da war irgendwie Messe oder so ein Shit und es war halt alles ausgebucht und ich habe nichts mehr gefunden, ich habe auch GoButler angeworfen und gefragt, hey, was gibt es nicht, kann ich noch ein Hotel haben? Und ich habe gesagt, ja, hier haben wir eins für 300 Euro oder eins für 600 Euro und ich habe gesagt, ja, ihr seid echt coole Typen, ihr seid echt coole Berliner Mitte-Hipster, aber so viel Geld habe ich nicht. Und dann tatsächlich einen Tag später habe ich nochmal geschaut und habe irgendwie auf so einem obskuren Schnäppchen Hotel Seite mit so ein paar Flash Animationen, wo man vielleicht schon hätte stutzig werden können, habe ich tatsächlich noch ein Schnäppchen gefunden, tatsächlich direkt in der Straße, in der auch unsere Redaktion ist, wo ich mir dachte, hm, das ist schon sehr, sehr gut. Das war zu einfach. Das war zu einfach. habe mir dieses Hotel gebucht, dann auch Bestätigung bekommen per E-Mail, irgendwie alles wie immer auch. Also alles wunderbar eigentlich. Und habe dann allerdings tatsächlich, glaube ich, so sechs Stunden, bevor ich hätte einchecken können, eine Mail. Also habe dann alles darauf angeboten, habe meine Sachen mitgenommen, nichts anderes mehr gesucht, habe fest mitgerechnet, da zu schlafen zu können. Sechs Stunden, bevor ich hätte einchecken können, kam die Mail, ja folgendes, ja wir haben ihre Buchung storniert. Aus technischen Gründen konnten wir ihre Buchung leider nicht mehr so wahrnehmen, wie das. Ich hab die Mailer gelesen, es klang eher so wie, ja, wir haben jetzt einen Gefallen getan. Okay, wir haben es jetzt für sie storniert, wie sie gewünscht haben. Bitteschön! Wir haben storniert, am Ball, ich hoffe, es ist alles okay, trotzdem weiterhin, und so haben sich wie die Kings dargestellt. Aber das ist wirklich eine Scheiss-Situation, wirklich eine Scheiss-Situation, wenn du kein Hotel hast und du weißt, du kriegst kein... Ich habe die auch selten so böse erlebt. Ja, ich weiß, allerdings, vielleicht hast du es schon vergessen, ich war richtig wütend und richtig pisst und es war richtig scheisse, allerdings hatte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt eine dumme Perücke auf und ein scheiss Kostüm an, ja, und ich fand es so geil, weil du direkt neben mir saßst und du einerseits Mitleid und es tut mir leid, andererseits konntest du mich nicht ernst nehmen, weil ich einfach so scheiße aussah gerade. Der gleiche Auftritt in der Sendung, wer ihn gesehen hat, weiß ja, wie ich aussah. Auf jeden Fall kann ich mir so gut vorstellen, dass man auch Leute irgendwie, die gerade irgendwie, Mutter ist gerade gestorben und man sagt, ich kann jetzt einfach nicht Mitleid mit dir haben, weil du siehst so bescheuert aus gerade. Das war tatsächlich sehr lustig. Und es ist auch einfach nichts Schöneres, als in der Situation auch noch ausgelacht zu werden. Naja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, aber die haben nicht nur storniert, die haben auch gesagt, ja, wir haben eine Alternative für sie rausgesucht, komplett am Arsch der Welt, komplett außerhalb von Köln, kommt man ja einfach hin, ach nee, Moment, Moment mal, die Zugführer streiken ja, ah ja, blöd, na ja, habe ich auf jeden Fall bei dieser Alternative angerufen. Und ich meine, man hat ja gewisse Vorstellungen, wenn man ein Hotel anruft, bei dem Wort Hotel hat man direkt ein Bild vor dem Kopf, so Kronleuchter, so Sessel, toll, Marmor, ein Jacuzzi im Zimmer, zwei Jacuzzi im Zimmer, Leute mit Hütchen, nettes Personal, zwei Jacuzzi und kein Zimmer, so ein Pfefferminz-Plättchen auf dem Tisch. Drei Jacuzzi. Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Genau, rufe ich da an in einem Hotel und es geht niemand ran. Und das ist schon mal so, okay, in einem Hotel geht niemand ran? Das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass ich in einem Hotel angerufen habe, es geht niemand ran. Außer so sehr spät mitten in der Nacht, wenn der letzte Mensch mal kurz eine blöde Nachtschicht hat
und dann alleine in der Theke steht und dann weinend nicht rangeht,
um sich Rat zu machen.
Und dann fällt ihm ein, oh, scheiße, ich arbeite,
ich bin gar nicht zu Hause und dann doch rangeht.
Es geht immer einer ran.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich fünf Minuten später nochmal angerufen
und dann hat sich so ein Typ gemerkt, ja, hallo,
ja, hallo, guten Tag, Florian Timmer mein Name,
bin ich da bei einem, wo bin ich denn hier? Ja, Sie sind bei A&T. Ja, ist das ein Hotel? Ach so, ja, ja, hallo, was kann ich denn für Sie tun? Also auch so komplett auf den falschen Fuss erwischt, gerade in vier Firmen gleichzeitig geführt und auf jeden Fall, ja, ich komme ja heute bei Ihnen vorbei, ja, ja, da hat ein Kumpel von mir angerufen, hat gesagt, dass Sie kommen und so, alles okay.
Also ganz strange. Auf jeden Fall war ich dann da irgendwie so ein alter...
Das ist wirklich das Letzte, was man hören will.
Ja, wirklich, das Wort Kumpel ist wirklich das Letzte, was man hören will, wenn es um Hotelreservierung geht.
Keine Ahnung, was da war, ja, mein Kumpel hat angerufen.
Auf jeden Fall war ich dann da bei so einem alten türkischen Herrn, kam auch mitten in der Nacht an, irgendwie musste ihn extra nochmal rausklingeln, war ganz unangenehm.
Und tatsächlich auch ein ganz komisches Zimmer, es war auch kein Hotel, es war einfach ein Haus, einfach ein normales Haus mit normalen Zimmern, wo Leute drin gewohnt haben, wo halt heute ich drin wohne und nicht irgendwie die Frau vom Türken. Und das war echt ein ganz komisches Bett auch zum Beispiel, vor allem mit der grössten Bettdecke, die ich in meinem Leben je gesehen habe. Das war echt so sehr, die war mindestens vier mal drei Meter gross, also wirklich riesengross. Und die war vor allem auch so wahnsinnig dick und so schwer. Also das war so ein Riesenmonstrum, wie wenn du drei Matratzen in Bettwäsche stecken würdest. So ungefähr war diese Bettdecke. Und ich dachte mir, komm. Ich finde sowas ja immer toll, ich finde sowas ja immer toll. Ich bin auch wahnsinnig gerne in Amerika, finde ich das total geil, weil die diese Riesenbetten haben, wo man dann denkt, boah, das ist ein Riesenbett, was kann man da alles machen und im Endeffekt nichts, weil man es hat ein Bett und man kann darauf schlafen und man denkt immer, boah, wie geil, diese unendliche Möglichkeiten, ein Riesenbett, eine Riesendecke, ich finde das immer total geil, diese Vorstellung und dann versinkt man da so drin, ist schon ganz geil. Aber das Zimmer war auch nicht so sauber und das Bett war auch nicht so sauber und du denkst dir irgendwie so, wie viele Dreckschichten sind jetzt in dieser, also so Schichten Dreck und dann nochmal eine Schicht Besucher und dann wieder Schichten Dreck und dann ich oben drauf. Also ganz, ganz komisch. Wenn schon die Bettwannen so in Schichten, so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so in so Also verschiedene Level. Man kann als gute Bettbeinigung zu hoch aufsteigen. Kannst du nicht hoch schlafen?
Naja.
Kannst du gut in neuen Betten schlafen?
Nicht wirklich.
Also wenn du eine erste Nacht irgendwo bist, kannst du da gut schlafen?
Überhaupt nicht, überhaupt nicht. Bei mir ist es tatsächlich die Grundregel, wenn ich in einem fremden Bett übernachte, die erste Nacht kann ich nicht schlafen, egal was es ist.
Die zweite Nacht und so geht dann schon in Ordnung und so, die erste Nacht kann ich einfach schlicht nicht schlafen.
Das heißt, wenn mir eine anbietet, hey, du kannst eine Nacht bei mir übernachten, dann heißt das für mich, ja gut, ich kann auch einfach vier Stunden lange am Hauptbahnhof sitzen und nichts tun, weil ich werde nicht schlafen können. Das ist einfach so. Ich bin da einfach so ein heimeliges Heimchen und das ist aber ganz schön uncool, also vor allem, weil du auch sehr viel zwischen Städten verbringst und sehr oft irgendwo Fremde schläfst. Aber ich habe tatsächlich mittlerweile nicht mehr so das Problem, nicht zu schlafen tatsächlich. Man gewöhnt sich da tatsächlich ein bisschen. Also jede Woche, eine Nacht schlafe ich nicht. Also war es die letzte Zeit so während der Staffelproduktion. Und da gewöhnt man sich auch irgendwann dran. Das ist halt dann einfach so. Und das ist auch okay. Also ich glaube, man kann sich echt an alles gewöhnen. Das ist so meine Lektion. Also auch Schlafentzug, glaube ich, ist auch kein Problem für mich. Oh cool. Kein Ding. Obwohl, da würde ich tatsächlich gerne mal mich mit so einem Schläfer unterhalten, der das beruflich macht. Und zwar die Frage. Ja, ich glaube, den nennt man Schläfer. Und zwar die Frage, kann man also jetzt im Bett liegen und nicht schlafen, wir nennen es jetzt mal Dösen, umrechnen in Schlafenszeit. Also drei Stunden Dösen ist genauso entspannt wie eine Stunde schlafen. Oder musst du einfach schlafen, sonst hast du keine Chance. Nein, kann ich dir beantworten? Okay, bitte. Du brauchst eine Tiefschlafphase. Das ist ja auch bei starken Schnarchern so, dass sie diese Tiefschlafphase nicht erreichen, weil sie sich meistens selber aufwecken. Gesamte Seriosität verloren schon im ersten Satz. Tiefschlafphase. Stiefschmachphase. Stiefschmachphase. Nein, du kannst, also du musst diese REM-Phase, REM-Phase, das ist die Tiefschlafphase, die musst du erreichen, und da verarbeitest du Dinge, und da baust du Energie wieder auf. Und wenn du die nicht erreichst, das ist völlig für den Arsch. Du kannst Dösen, wie du willst, ist es einfach für den Arsch. Das ist einfach wie verschenkte Lebenszeit. Dösen ist völlig verschenkt. Ist das wirklich so? Ja, und deswegen fände ich auch so geil, wenn man sich einfach selber einschläfern könnte. Warum gibt es nicht an jedem Bett irgendwie so eine Spritze, die man sich reinhaut, um dann direkt zu pennen? Die Lebenszeit ist einfach da. Also du hast dann, wenn Dösen einschlafen, das bringt dir nichts. Das bringt dir überhaupt gar nichts. Du denkst nach über Dinge, das kannst du aber den ganzen Rest des Tages machen. Und irgendwann schläfst du und das hilft dann erst. Aber diese Stunden, die du mit Einschlafen verbringst, bringen dir nichts. Aber ich habe mal gehört, dass man das auch stark überschätzt, dass man immer denkt, man würde total lange wachliegen, aber eigentlich sind es nur fünf Minuten. Ja, aber da habe ich zum letzten Mal gehört. Aber ich habe zum Beispiel letztens einen Podcast gehört mit jemandem, der meinte, der hat so eine Art Chakra, irgendwie orientalische Gesänge-CD oder was auch immer. Und da gibt es ein Stück, das ist genau 15 Minuten lang und er hat sich antrainiert, weil er das immer vorm Einschlafen hört und er hat sich antrainiert, genau wenn es fertig ist, einzuschlafen und genau das zu triggern, dass er einschlägt. Das ist ganz schön krass. Wo ich mir genau sagen würde, bei mir würde es genau den gegenteiligen Effekt hervorzugen, weil ich mir denke, okay, du musst jetzt einschlafen, du musst jetzt einschlafen, das Lied ist gleich vorbei, ansonsten hast du kein Lied mehr, du musst jetzt einschlafen, du, ja okay, du bist nicht eingeschlafen, okay, von vorne, nächstes 15 Minuten, das würde mich wahnsinnig. Ich würde nämlich dabei so eine geile Choreo entwickeln, ich würde das orientalische Lied total lieb gewinnen, würde dann so eine Choreo dazu machen und würde dann jeden Abend aufhören. Der Automatismus, ich finde auch, Schlafen, Automatismus, das geht nicht so zusammen, das glaube ich nicht, dass das geht, dass man sich selber so trainieren kann. Genau wie Leute, die sagen, man kann Träume steuern, wenn man das lange macht. Kann man sich selber Träume steuern. Ja, das ist ein anderes Thema, da können wir auch mal drüber reden. Ist heute vielleicht nicht die richtige Folge dafür. Aber schläfst du auf dem Rücken oder auf der Seite? Ui, das ist sehr intim plötzlich. Ganz hart hart. Schläfst du eigentlich nackt? Ne, ich schlafe eigentlich auf dem Rücken oder auf der Seite, ist mir völlig egal, manchmal auch auf dem Bauch. Ist mir völlig egal, ich schlafe einfach wie ich gerade Bock habe. Wow, crazy. Ich bin ein crazy Typ, ich bin ein Risk-Taker. Ich habe mal gehört, also man kann ja auch, was vielleicht hinpasst in dieses orientalische Ding, man kann ja auch sich so Hypnose-Sachen machen, also man kann sich auch bei Hypnose einschläfern lassen, bestimmt. Bei Spotify gibt es bestimmt auch sowas, so Hypnose-Leute, die reden irgendwie, ja, und wenn ich jetzt schnippse, dann schläfst du tief und fest ein und wachst erst wieder auf, und dann abonnierst du doch schnell Spotify Premium und dann wachst du wieder auf. So was, und dann habe ich eben gelesen ich eben gelesen bei Bild, oder letzte Woche oder so, da gibt es diese vier, sieben, acht Regel. Also man muss atmen, das ist eine Atmungstechnik. Du musst komplett einatmen, das Ganze vier Sekunden lang drin lassen, dann zur Hälfte ausatmen. Wir machen das mal, wir machen das zusammen. Komm, Florian, stehen. Steh mal auf, steh mal auf, mach mal die Augen zu.
Oder setz dich hin, das ist eigentlich völlig egal.
Ich sitze, ich ziehe mich aus.
Dann sitzt du und zieh dich aber wenigstens aus.
Okay, die ganze Luft rein.
Jetzt musst du vier Sekunden was halten, jetzt zur Hälfte raus.
Und immer durch die Nase ausatmen, habe ich vergessen zu sagen, ich bin ein schlechter Typ.
Und dann musst du das sieben Sekunden lang drin lassen, jetzt zur Hälfte, und jetzt acht Sekunden lang durch die Nase langsam ausatmen. Und das macht dich völlig müde. Das ist wirklich so, wenn du das ein paar Mal machst, das macht dich völlig müde. Also komplett alles reinsaugen, vier Sekunden lang anhalten, die Hälfte raus, sieben Sekunden lang anhalten, dann acht Sekunden lang langsam durch die Nase ausatmen. Und das macht dich wirklich müde. Wäre mir aber zu viel Arbeit tatsächlich. Ja, und du musst so viel rechnen und dann die Wurzel aus zwei und jetzt musst du doch einatmen. Das macht dich auch ein bisschen fertig. Aber trotzdem ganz interessant, dass es so Atemungstechniken gibt. Apropos Träumen. Ich habe ja irgendwann mal angefangen, ein Traumtagebuch zu führen, weil ich das tatsächlich sehr spannend fand. Und wenn du willst, können wir mal ein bisschen reingucken. Kann ich dir ein paar Träume von mir vorlesen? Du liest vor und ich versuche, die zu deuten. Ich habe hier so eine Deutungsseite offen. Okay, also ich habe drei Träume vorbereitet, die in der Absurdität immer weiter steigen. Ich freue mich, ich habe auch ein paar Sachen draus zu hauen. Ich sage jetzt auch mal nicht, aus welcher Zeit die kommen, damit du erraten kannst, ob das aktuelle Probleme sind, die mich umtreiben oder nicht. Okay. Erster Traum. Also er geht schon los mit Anführungszeichen, muss man dazu sagen. Also die ersten beiden Worte sind in Anführungszeichen gesetzt. Aus Versehen, in Anführungszeichen, rauche ich Pilze und gehe euphorisch, in Anführungszeichen, stoned in die Stadt. Ich will noch etwas essen, bevor ich zur Arbeit gehe, damals habe ich beim Callcenter gearbeitet, kann ich ja noch sagen. Bei McDonald's schlafe ich ein und als ich aufwache, merke ich, dass ich meine Abendschicht verpasst habe. Es ist 23 Uhr. Ich telefoniere mit Markus, dem Schichtleiter, und will noch kommen, verlaufe mich aber und komme auf eine Art Lagergelände, wo ich das Hauptgatter aufsperre und eintrete.
Ich gehe wieder und schliesse ab. Ich nehme eine grosse, rostige Kette mit.
Noch bevor ich das Gelände verlassen kann, kommt mir ein Auto entgegen, dessen Insassen mich fragen, was ich denn mit der Kette will, anscheinend die Besitzer oder Arbeiter auf dem Gelände.
Ich behaupte, ich hätte Angst auf dem Weg zur U-Bahn und hätte sicherheitshalber die Kette mitgenommen. Sie sehen das ein und backen in einem Haus einen Kuchen. Sie drücken Kuchenboden in eine Schokoladenmasse hoch und runter und analysieren physikalisch das Gesetz des ... Sie beten mich zu bleiben und der Kuchen sieht sehr gut aus, aber ich entscheide mich zu gehen. Ich muss los, auch wenn das überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr hat, die Schicht ist eh bereits vorbei, trotzdem ist mir das wichtiger. Okay, okay, ist natürlich ein krasser Twist hinten, also der Kuchen kam unerwartet, aber irgendwie auch nicht, wenn man dich kennt, auch irgendwie nicht. Ja, aber das finde ich auch so geil an Träumen, dass so komplett random Plotwists einfach erscheinen, so jetzt geht's um Kuchen. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, einfach so eine Gehirnaktivität, wo man genau merkt, dass die Synapsen einfach kein Ziel verfolgen, sondern einfach irgendwo hinschießt, wo sie gerade sind. Ja, genau, ich komme hier nicht weiter. Genau. Einfach hingehen, wo sie gerade Bock drauf haben. Also ich interpretiere das so, auch die Kette zeigt mir ganz klar, du hängst in deinem Arbeitsleben fest, du hast aber trotzdem immer Hunger.
Also du hängst in deinem Arbeitsleben fest und du willst aus diesen Kettenhänden herausbrechen, sogar so sehr, dass du sie wirklich sprichwörtlich mitnimmst.
Du nimmst die Ketten mit, in denen du hängst, in dieser Arbeit, in der du festhängst.
Vor allem.
Du hast da nicht mehr Lust drauf, du hast da nicht mehr Lust drauf.
Du willst ausbrechen und da ist McDonalds hängen, du lässt es sogar schleifen, dass du bei McDonald's die Schicht verpenst. Und dann kommt wieder der Hunger, dieses Hungergefühl, das, was dich dein ganzes Leben lang begleitet. Das ist eigentlich das, was Florentin will antreibt, Hunger. Und deswegen nimmst du den Kuchen am Ende gern dankend an von Arbeitern, wo dein alltaglich einholt. Das ist so das Ding, glaube ich. Vor allem, ich finde es ja interessant, dass ich die Kette mitnehme und behaupte, sie würde mir Sicherheit verhelfen. Allerdings, sie an der Kette natürlich eigentlich eher ein negatives Symbol ist, im Sinne von etwas Festketten. Aber es ist ja auch Sicherheit. Also man sagt, ich bin gerne angekettet, weil es gibt mir Sicherheit, allerdings eng ich die Kette auch ein. Oder du kettest sehr gerne Leute an, vielleicht auch einfach, weil du hast die Kette ja in der Hand. Du kannst ja mit der machen, was du willst. Ja, und die Leute fragen mich, hey, warum hast du denn die Kette? Ja, das gibt mir Sicherheit. Ja, völlig okay. Völlig okay. Finde ich auch okay, ja. Also vielleicht sollte man auch mal nachdenken, ob die Ketten, die man so im Leben hat, wirklich Sicherheit geben oder ob es nicht besser wäre, sie zu durchbrechen. Ich hoffe, ich konnte helfen mit der Deutung. Absolut. Der nächste bitte, der nächste Traum bitte.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du zum nächsten sagst.
Herzlich willkommen beim Traum der Chef von Tietze, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Hallo.
Ja, also mir ist folgendes, habe ich folgendes geträumt.
Mein Vater und ich schlafen in einem Zimmer in Berchtesgaden bei meiner Oma.
Als sich meine Mutter bei meiner Oma fragt, in welchem Zimmer ich denn geschlafen habe, kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Keines ihrer Zimmer passt zu meiner Erinnerung. Oma fängt an mitzuraten, in welchem Zimmer ich geschlafen haben könnte, was Mutter sehr begeistert und sie ist plötzlich sehr euphorisch und vital, denn sie meint, dass Oma letztens noch nicht mal Eimer sagen konnte. Meine Mutter zeigt mir Bilder von einem Ereignis, wo ich Moment, Moment, nötige dir mal Eimer. Ja, habe ich schon. Ich habe unscheinlich gerade aufgeschrieben. Moment, meine Mutter zeigt mir Bilder von einem Ereignis, wo ich und andere Jungs in Soldatenuniformen auf Ski in den verschneiten Bergen einen Mittelalterumzug mit Pferden und allem drum und dran. Okay, okay, stopp. Ich muss sie kurz sagen. Kannst du das nochmal vorlesen, bitte? Ich komme nicht mehr mit. Alles klar. Meine Mutter zeigt mir Bilder von einem Ereignis, wo ich und andere Jungs in Soldatenuniformen auf Ski in den verschneiten Bergen einen Mittelalterumzug mit Pferden und allem drum und dran mit Salutschüssen begleiten sollten. Schnitt zu diesem Ereignis. Meine Mutter macht Fotos, ich spiele mit meinem Gewehr herum und fahre den Hang voraus, lege mich in den Schnee und fange an, auf den Umzug zu schiessen. Ich treffe recht gut, einige Leute sterben, auch eintreffende Polizisten. Einem anderen befehle ich, er solle sich nach einem besseren Punkt umsehen, von dem aus ich schiessen könnte. Nachdem der Zug sehr schnell wird, ich hatte einige Schüsse in die Menge abgegeben, ging ich vom Berg herab und sah aus dem Umzug einen Kerl in Rüstung, der hinter mir um die Strassenecke kam. Mein Partner spekulierte über die Rolle des Gerüsteten im Plot des Umzugs. Er ist der schwarze Ritter, meinte er. Als er von hinten auf dem Umzug zuging, feuerte ich einen Schuss auf ihn ab, der von der Rüstung abprallte und der den Zug von diesem Geräusch auf ihn aufmerksam wurde und ihn angriff. Jetzt musste ich die Tatwaffe loswerden. Eine Art Hundehütte mit einer schlafenden Ziege darin versprach ein gutes Versteck. Aber als ich das Gewehr unterbringen wollte, brach das Vordach der Hütte ein und auf die Ziege. Sie öffnete nur verschlafen die Augen, und ich musste ein anderes Versteck suchen. Nachdem noch zwei streunende Douchebags mich daran hinderten, offen nach einem Versteck zu suchen, lief ich über ein Feld auf der Spitze des Hügels, wobei ich bemerkte, dass auf dem Feld Blumen in geraden parallelen Linien gepflanzt wurden, die immer unreifer wurden, je weiter ich durchs Feld lief, sie mussten wohl zeitlich versetzt gepflanzt worden sein. Am Waldrand angekommen sah ich einen Pflock im Boden, der als Markierung gelten sollte, und ich betrat an dieser Stelle den Wald und zählte ein paar Bäume ab und legte das Gewehr mit einem Zettel darauf unter einen Baum und begann alles mit Nadeln vom Waldboden zu überhäufen. Ich bemerkte einen grossen, stöhnenden Mann, der in meiner Nähe durch den Wald streifte.
Ich ignorierte ihn erst und schaufelte weiter, verliess dann wieder den Wald, aber er hatte mich gesehen und folgte mir. Meine letzten Gedanken waren an die Kategorisierung von Kreaturen in das schwarze Auge und dass es hier im Real Life keine so klare Trennung gibt und man als Spielleiter eigentlich alles einbauen könnte, was man will. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen, man muss dazu sagen, ich spiele ein Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspiel namens Das schwarze Auge und ist nicht so wichtig, aber ich glaube, die Hauptstory ist durchgekommen. Ich glaube, das braucht man aber, um den Traum zu verstehen. Weiss ich nicht. Völlig, also, erst mal, dass du diese Amoklaufgedanken auch hast.
Und dann, wo wir kurz noch mal dazu, also das einfachste Wort, was dir eingefallen ist im Traum, ist Eimer. Deine Oma konnte noch nicht mal jetzt mehr Eimer sagen. Es riecht schon gut. Auf allem, stell dir mal vor. Der Unterbewusstsein hält Eimer für das einfachste Wort, was man jemals aussprechen kann. Aber stell dir mal vor, das sagt jemand zu dir. Ach toll, Oma redet wieder. Letzte Woche konnte sie noch nicht mal Eimer sagen. In welchem Kontext ist das aufgefallen, dass sie nicht Eimer sagen konnte? Und dann möchte ich bitte, dass man wirklich einen Mittelaltermarkt in einer Skilandschaft vollbringt, wo man mit Army-Kostüm und Gewehren rumfährt.
Es ist Paradise.
Ich finde auch so gut, dass ich anscheinend meine
Aufgabe falsch verstanden habe. Ich sollte den
Umzug mit Salutschüssen begleiten
und gehe da hin und fange einfach an,
auf den Umzug zu schießen.
Moment, so war das
nicht gemein. Es fühlt sich
komisch an. Wie sieht es aus mit der Interpretation? Ja, ich bin völlig, ich habe auch ausgestaltet bei einmal, ich konnte das nicht mal ernst nehmen. Da verfein ich mich auch, wie ich so viel merken kann. Also wenn ich mir träume, also ich kann mir nur sehr kurze Träume merken, die von der Dramaturgie relativ klar sind und relativ schnell auch erzählt sind. Ja, aber man muss dazu sagen, man hat auch da ein schlechtes Gedächtnis an das Gedächtnis. Man kann sich nicht immer daran erinnern, woran man sich erinnern konnte, kurz nach dem Traum. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen, denn du wirklich direkt, nachdem du aufwachst, niederschreibst, kannst du dich an sehr viel erinnern. Du vergisst es nur so schnell und dadurch vergisst du auch, was du da wusstest. Ja, weil die Schnapsen sich halt, das ist das Gleiche, nur sehr schnell damit beschäftigt haben und es ist halt nicht im Langzeitgedächtnis. Ist halt so. Ja, aber es es ist tatsächlich so, dass du dich noch, also meiner Erfahrung nach, man sich noch an relativ viel erinnern kann. Danach, genau, das habe ich auch schon mal gehört. Ja, crazy, keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht deuten, absolut weird, völlig weird. Schuldthema vielleicht, ich will das Gewehr verstecken und schaff's nicht. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite auch Mordgedanken, ich weiß nicht, war das alles so gesund? Naja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man das alles eins zu eins übersetzen kann, nur weil du davon träumst. Also ich träume wirklich sehr real, aber vielleicht kurz auch mal eine Ausnahme. Soll ich mal einen Traum von mir erzählen? Aber du musst das aus dem Gedächtnis erzählen. Ich weiß nicht, habe ich schon mal erzählt, glaube ich. Ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt hier in dem Podcast. Also, ich war sehr gut mit Löwen befreundet in dem Traum. Die Löwen waren meine besten Freunde.
Wir haben alles zusammen gemacht, wir hatten den grössten Fun überhaupt.
Es war total lustig, geile Welt, yeah, Löwen befreundet sein, ist ja auch irgendwie cool.
Und dann war ich halt, ich war ein Mensch, muss man dazu sagen.
Und dann war Karneval und ich habe mich als Antilope verkleidet und dann wurde ich gefressen.
Als Gag, als Ironie.
Und ich wurde gefressen, weil ich mich als Antilope verkleidet habe, weil Löwen fressen Antilopen. Und das war sehr traurig und sehr schlimm, und ich bin nur noch aufgewacht, und es war halt ein sehr schlimmer Traum, weil meine besten Freunde mich aufgefressen haben. Das war ein Anfängerfehler. Ich war aber, na ja, ich war sehr, sehr gut verkleidet vielleicht. Ich war vielleicht der bestverkleidetste Mensch zu dem Zeitpunkt in dem Traum. Das ist aber auch eine zweifelhafte Botschaft. Deine Freunde wollen dich auffressen. Ich glaube, die Botschaft ist die, dass ich, also Löwe sind ja sehr coole Tiere. Und das sind so die Könige der Tiere. Und dass ich mit Löwen befreundet war, aber dem, die ich standhalten konnte, diesem Leistungsdruck, dem ich jederzeit ausgewertet war. Genau, und ich halt total verbocke an diesem einen speziellen Tag, der haltneval ist, das sage, glaube ich, viel aus. Ich war mit Löwen befreundet, aber ich konnte dem nicht gerecht werden. Also du hast kein hohes Vertrauen in deine Freundschaften. Du hast das Gefühl, dass deine Freunde besser sind als du und dich jederzeit auffressen können. Ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Sowas vielleicht? Ja. Aber warum hast du dich als Gazelle verkleidet? Also wolltest du dich vielleicht selbst aufgeben für deine Freunde, dass sie dich fressen können? Konntest du dem Druck nicht mehr standhalten? Ich weiß nicht, wo wo. Keine Ahnung. Und neulich habe ich geträumt, dass ich mit Heidi Klum telefoniere. Warum das zum Teufel? Ich meine, ich finde ja nicht immer so cool, ich weiss auch nichts über sie. Und ich habe mich einfach in einem Traum getrachtet, dass du glaubst, irgendwer hat mir den Hörer gegeben. Also ich baue immer Leute aus meiner Umgebung in Träume ein. Das ist ganz toll so. Ja, das ist ganz natürlich. Aber Heidi Klum ist ja ein Stand-in. Die steht ja für jemand anderen. Wenn du von Heidi Klum träumst, ist wahrscheinlich nicht Heidi Klum damit gemeint. Ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Und dann gab es mal einen Traum, wo ich mit David Letterman unterwegs war, wo ich auf fließend Englisch gesprochen habe. Hier ist klar, dass das auch alles Family-Guy-Folgen sind, also nur zur Info. Was denn, mit Heidi Klum telefonieren? Ja, die ganzen Träume. Also, bist du ein bisschen beeinflussbar, mein lieber. Vielleicht, ist es einfach so. Oder du klaust einfach Träume. Was mir sehr oft passiert ist in der Tat so, dass ich aufwache und gerade einen Witz geträumt habe und ich bin völlig, ich bin überrascht, wow, wie brilliant, das ist der beste Gag ever, schreibt mir den dann auf in Notizen wirklich in der echten Welt und schläft dann wieder ein. Und dann wache ich morgens dann auf und dann sehe ich auf meinem Handy so ganz weirde Notizen, die überhaupt gar keinen Sinn ergeben und die überhaupt nicht lustig sind und die gar nicht sein können, wo ich mir einfach aber im Traum dachte, boah, das ist total der geile Gag. Und das ist halt dieses Ding, wenn Träume auf Wirklichkeit treffen, die halten meistens der Überprüfung eigentlich nicht stand, weil die einfach nicht real sind. Und das ist immer sehr lustig. Okay, einen Traum habe ich noch. Okay, ich bin gespannt. Go. Auf einem Bahnhof verbringe ich die Nacht und schlafe auf einer Wartebank. Eine junge Frau schmiegt sich an mich. Ich wärme sie und wir schlafen gemeinsam ein. Okay, okay, soll man das wirklich aufs Klo gehen, allerdings ist dieses komplett verdreckt und auf dem Boden ist überall Kotze verteilt.
Außerdem geht das Licht nicht richtig und ich taste mich zwischen den Kotzeflecken hindurch in eine Kabine.
Bevor ich diese betreten kann, kommen einige Herren in Anzügen herein, unter anderem mein Chef, und sie wollen wissen, was passiert ist.
Ich erzähle, aus irgendeinem Grund gibt es eine Wetten-das-Aufzeichnung in einem grossen Schwimmbecken in einem Studio nebenan. Ich und ein paar profillose Freunde, Schrägstrich Kollegen, schwimmen in dem Schwimmbecken herum, bis die Show, bei der erstaunlich wenige Leute anwesend sind und wir haben nicht zugesehen, wir dachten uns schon, dass das nichts wird, vorbei ist. Der Moderator, in Klammern David Hasselhoff, verabschiedet sich gerade, als er hinter sich einen Zettel an der Wand kleben sieht. Er reißt ihn ab und liest ihn vor, auf ihm steht Gags tot. Mit entsetztem Gesicht zerreißt er ihn, wird wütend und fängt an, andere Zettel, die überall auf der Bühne verteilt sind und hinter ihm kleben, auf gebrochenem Deutsch vorzulesen, unter anderem, ich mache gerne Butterschnitzel, Käse, ich bin böse, grosse Empörung, das und mehr, was vor Wetten, dass eigentlich hätte stattfinden sollen und was zwischen Wetten, dass und der Kloverwüstung passiert ist, aber daran kann ich mich nicht mehr genau erinnern, das alles erzähle ich den Herren, während sie gebannt zuhören. Das ist der letzte Traum. Das ist der letzte Traum, den du hattest? Nee, ist nur der letzte, den ich jetzt rausguckt habe. Ach du Schein. Du bist völlig kaputt. Auf der anderen Seite, diese Zettel, die überall rumkleben, ich glaube, die wünschst du dir vielleicht auch.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Also du wünschst dir Zettel, die in die Richtung weisen vielleicht. Ja, aber ich finde auch wieder den Stimmungswachsen, du hast schon völlig zu Recht bemerkt, okay, emotionaler Traum, aha, eine junge Frau, aber die kommt einfach nicht mehr vor. Aber das passt auch so zu deinem Leben.
Es passt nur zu deinem Leben.
Es kommen so emotionale Momente, die einfach völlig ignoriert werden.
Und dann, hey, show, wetten das mit David Hasselhoff. Genau, das stimmt. Das stimmt, man kann es eigentlich gut zusammenfassen. Also erstmal, Beziehung emotional endet in vollgekotztem Klo, absolute Katastrophe. Und als Leute reinkommen und mich fragen, was ist denn hier los, also wissen wollen, warum alles schlecht war. Drittest du ab? Lüge ich erstens, weil ich hätte ja auch einfach sagen können, ja, das war nicht ich, sondern ich lüge und sage, ja, anderes Thema, nebenan wird gerade nebenan wird gerade Wetten, dass aufgezeichnet. Kurz ein bisschen off-topic. Das ist auch die beste Möglichkeit. Ich bin so zurückgelehnt und habe so eine Kaffeetasse in der Hand, ich fühle mich wie so ein ganz alter Radiomoderator, irgendwie so eine Call-In-Show moderiert. So ein Psychoanalytiker, ja. Wo so ganz weirde, ja, noch nicht mal, nee, der es nicht dazu geschafft hat, wo er ganz weirde Leute anrufen und von den Träumen erzählen. Und der gar nicht mehr weiter weiß und noch keine Lust mehr darauf hat. Das ist ganz schön crazy. Aber allein die Vorstellung, David Hasselhoff moderiert Wetten, dass in einem Schwimmbad, wo nur vier Leute im Schwimmbad sind. Niemand hört zu und niemand macht es. Und die Leute werdenütend, weil ein Zettel, wo Käse draufsteht, vorliest und Entrüstung im Publikum finde ich auch sehr interessant. Oh, das gibt er nicht. Oh na, das hat er nicht gesagt. Käse. Naja gut. Vom Käse in gebrochenem Deutsch stehe ich mir auch sehr gut. Gute Wörter. Träumst du manchmal auch Träumen zweimal? Also das finde ich immer total... Ja, absolut. Ich hatte tatsächlich einen wiederkehrenden Traum, den ich schon ein paar Mal habe. Und das ist eher so ein Albtraum. Und jetzt ganz kurz, ich kann ja auch kurz zusammenfassen. Auf jeden Fall finde ich schon mal ganz geil. Die erste Ebene des Traums ist, ich schau Fernsehen. Die zweite Ebene des Traums ist, was im Fernseher passiert. Und zwar sieht man eine Doku, wie es irgendwie jetzt... Gibt es irgendwie einen neuen Trend oder so? Und zwar gibt es so eine Maschine, die kann man sich an den Kopf anschließen, und die Maschine versorgt dich mit allem. Du musst nichts mehr tun, du musst dich nicht bewegen, du kriegst Kalorien, du kriegst Gedanken, du kriegst Input, man muss sich vorstellen, du träumst gerade in einer Welt, wo alles möglich ist, und du guckst Fernsehen. Ja, aber ich gucke an diese Doku. Du hast aber gar keinen Fernsehen, muss man dazu sagen. Das heißt, du träumst, du wünschst dir sehnlichsten Fernsehen. Genau, mein innigster Wunsch, damit ich endlich diese Doku anschauen kann. Also diese Doku von dieser Maschine, die man sich an den Kopf klebt und die alles, also man hat überhaupt keine Bedürfnisse, man kriegt alles, wird stimuliert auf allen Ebenen, alles perfekt. Und dann geht eben dieses Reporter-Team in so eine Art Drogenkeller und schaut sich da so um und da sieht dann irgendwie so ganz viele Menschen, die alle nackt aufeinander liegen mit allen diesen Maschinen und die einfach nur komplett apathisch in die Kamera schauen, mit komplett glasigen Augen und die schon seit Jahren da unten liegen und die sind auch schon so ein bisschen zusammengewachsen. Das ist alles nur noch so eine eine, so eine grosse Menschmasse, die dann so ganz debil in die Kamera gucken und so ein bisschen hilflos, aber da irgendwie so vor sich hinvegetieren. Und den hatte ich ein paar Mal den Traum, den finde ich ein bisschen unheimlich. Das ist gruselig. Ja, es klingt vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig gruselig, aber in dem Ding ist es schon dieser Blick von diesen Leuten, die seit vier Jahren da unten hängen und nichts mehr tun und sich nicht bewegt haben, das ist schon... Ich hätte mal, also ich habe so ein paar Elemente, die ein paar Mal wieder aufgetaucht sind, unter anderem Heidi Klum, die sich wie roter Fahrrad durch mein Leben und der Monopolymann. Also ich bin sehr, sehr oft, ich bin sehr oft gefallen in Träumen. Immer wenn ich gefallen bin, habe ich unter mir drehend den Monopolymann gesehen, wie er lachend sich gedreht hat und dann war der Traum vorbei. Immer. Ich bin immer vom Fallen im Traum aufgewacht und immer hat sich der Monopolymann vor mir gedreht. Aber was heißt das, nur das Gesicht oder der ganze Monopolymann? Hat man schon mal jemanden ganz gesehen? Ich glaube schon, der ist auf der Packung und der fährt auch das Auto, glaube ich. Supergruseliger Kerl, sehr ominöser, sehr unseriöser Typ, sehr reich, sehr gute Möglichkeiten und sehr, weiß ich nicht, sehr unnahbarer Typ. Und der hat sich mir ausgelacht, wenn ich gefallen bin. Ich bin sehr aufgefallen, eigentlich in jedem Traum, kann auch in Holland gespielt haben, sehr tief gefallen. Weiß ich auch nicht, irgendwo hin. Ja, das ist die Magie in Träumen, da kann man sogar in Holland fallen. Naja, also ihr könnt ja gerne mal irgendwie selber analysieren, was diese Träume über uns aussagen. Ihr könnt ja auch mal Bilder malen von unseren Träumen oder irgendwas in der Richtung. Wir freuen uns natürlich immer wieder über Input von euch. Diese Beschäftigungstherapie, die wir immer raus haben. Ja, man muss auch Hausaufgaben geben. Nein, Leute, das Podcast-Bufo ist doch nicht nur ein Podcast, das ist Leiszeit. Ihr müsst euch von Kingston erstmal erholen. Ja, kommt muss auch Hausaufgaben geben. Leute, bleibt erstmal Leute. Ich weiß, ihr müsst euch von Pfingsten erstmal erholen. Ja, kommt erstmal runter. Kommt erstmal bitte runter von Pfingsten. War ein geiles Wochenende, aber jetzt müssen wir auch wieder normal. Das Leben geht weiter, das Leben geht normal weiter, der Alltag beginnt. Morgen schon wieder, ist schon wieder normaler Tag. Ich will auf das Podcast, das Podcast-Ufo soll eine ganze Bewegung werden. Das ist nicht nur ein Podcast, da steht Kunst dahinter, Lyrik, Film, verschiedene Medien, Tanz, Ausdruck, Malerei, Sport, das steht alles zusammen und das fände ich mal cool, wenn das Podcast-Ufo so ein Gesamtkunstwerk werden würde, wenn jemand mal einen Film dreht und mal einen Traum nachstellt oder irgendwie einen Comic. Wer war eigentlich der erste Mensch, der geträumt hat? Es war bestimmt ultra gruselig, weil du kannst es ja... Wir machen jetzt aber nicht die Rubrik an. Natürlich nicht. Ja, gut, aber ein bisschen Ordnung. Ja, es mies mal. Ich wollte nur ganz kurz darauf hin. Goldini, Goldini. Goldini, Goldini, Goldini. Goldini. Ich habe bestimmt auch viel von Pokémon geträumt früher, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Ich auch, auf jeden Fall. Bisschen gruselig zurückblicken, Goldinien hat. Ich träume auch immer, wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass die Firma gerade nicht so gut läuft, dann mache ich mich auch in Träumen immer fertig. Dann träume ich immer, wie meine Chefs mich feuern oder so, oder total demütigen. Sowas träume ich auch immer ganz oft, so ganz furchtbare Träume, wo ich mir auch immer denke, das hilft dir ja auch selber nicht, weil du kannst es ja nicht entscheiden, also unterbewusst denkst du ja anscheinend, dass Leute dich hassen, dass sie dich nicht träumen, dass sie dich feuern und dich voll demütigen. Ich glaube, man kann bei Trauminterpretation nicht immer so sagen, dass man sich das wünscht, was man träumt oder so. Ich glaube, das kann auch viel schichtiger sein. Vielleicht wünschst du dir sogar, dass du gefeuert wirst und dass du eigentlich, dass du viel mehr unter dieser
Anstellung leidest und dass du eigentlich unzufrieden bist und dass du, also vielleicht hat es noch verschiedene Facetten. Nur weil du von etwas träumst, heißt es nicht automatisch, dass du Angst davor hast oder so, das ist glaube ich vielschichtiger. Ja. Ich glaube, wenn es so einfach wäre, hätte Freud nicht den Nobelpreis gewonnen. Kann ich mir vorstellen. Der war das, ne, das war ein Genie schon, der Freud war schon ein krasser Typ.
Der Sigmund, ne? Ja, ja.
Er hat gesagt, alle Träume haben irgendwas mit Sex zu tun, ausser Träume, in denen man von Sex träumt. Da geht es um was anderes. Hast du die auch alle aufgeschrieben? Hast du auch alle deine Sexträume aufgeschrieben? Ich habe ein paar Sexträume aufgeschrieben. Die würde ich jetzt mal gerne hören. Die kann ich dir mal persönlich, wenn wir zu zweit sind,
wenn wir mal eine Kerze anmachen, dann kann ich dir die vorlesen, ja.
Es sind schon ein paar ganz gute Ideen dabei, ja.
Das ist nämlich ganz schön krass, weil ich habe das Gefühl,
ich meine, wir sind ja beide noch sehr jung,
und je jünger man ist, umso mehr träumt man ja auch davon.
Das ist ja schon ganz schön dreckig.
Ja.
Ja, müssen wir jetzt über das Stichwort feuchter Traum reden eigentlich? Haben Frauen eigentlich auch feuchte Träume? Ja, ich glaube, die haben sehr feuchte Träume. Ich glaube, die haben die feuchte Träume. Also jetzt in dem Sinne, also es lässt sich ja nicht eins zu eins übertragen, aber. Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, bei Männern ist das ja auch nur rein biologisch, weil es irgendwann einfach überläuft. Ich glaube, das ist einfach dann relativ klar getrennt.
Okay.
Schreibt es uns mal.
Wir haben ja so viele weibliche Zuhörer.
Ihr könnt uns mal ein bisschen die weibliche Anatomie erklären.
Lasst uns einfach ein bisschen teilhaben an euren wundervollen, mysteriösen Körpern.
Erklärt uns mal, wie es bei euch eigentlich so funktioniert. Erklärt uns einfach von A bis Z einfach mal Rundumschlag.
Erklärt uns einfach mal alles.
Wie es so funktioniert, wie es so tickt, wie man so macht, was so machen muss, um euch so beeindrucken. So was vielleicht mal erzählen. Ja, dir ist schon klar, dass die alle 15 sind. Also ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt erzählen, du musst irgendwie Bruno Mars hören und Justin Bieber auswendig kennen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in deiner... Bewegen wir uns damit auch so am Rande der Legalität. Ich glaube, es wird schon langsam kritisch, ja. Ich glaube, man kann keine Minderjährigen fragen, ob sie schon mal einen feuchten Traum haben. Ich glaube, das geht schon tatsächlich in die Strafwelligkeit. Ich hätte schon mal einen Fiebertraum. Also das ist ganz schön krass. Dann denkst du nämlich, das, was du träumst, wäre real. Und wenn das noch ein Albtraum ist im schlechtesten Fall, dann drehst du völlig am Rad, du drehst völlig durch. Und dann bin ich auch irgendwie aufgestanden. Und daran erinnere ich mich auch noch, ich bin gegen das Aquarium gelaufen.
Die haben so einen Streifen mitgemacht,
diese Fische. Auch die mussten
Fieberträume mitmachen, die spätestens in der Nacht
gegen das Aquarium laufen und es ist fast umgekippt.
Und ich bin durch die Wohnung gelaufen und habe geschrien,
ich will mich umbringen, hol den Krankenwagen.
Wie am Spieß habe ich das geschrien,
obwohl das natürlich nicht so war. Und warum sollte man
die Polizei... Alter! Ja, ich weiß auch nicht warum. Aber das war in den Rückblicken sehr lustig eigentlich. Also natürlich nicht für die alle Beteiligten da, war es ein totaler Schock. Aber es war einfach so ein Traum. Man träumt halt Dinge und dann sagt man das laut und dann ist es einfach weird. Und wenn du einen Fiebertraum hast, ist es ganz schön krank. Sollte man vielleicht rausschneiden jetzt an der Stelle. Bist du schon mal geschlafwandelt? Ja, da, zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ach so, ich bin auch ein einziges Mal schlafgewandelt in meinem ganzen Leben. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schon erzählt habe. Auf jeden Fall war das in Wien, da waren wir mit der ganzen Klasse unterwegs und so Klassenfahrt irgendwas. Ach so, die Momente, wo man gerade nicht, bitte lass mich einfach normal wie jedes Mal schlafen. Und wenn ich einmal bitte nicht schlafwandelt, dann jetzt. Ja genau, Schlafwandelt, unfeuchter Traum und alles gleichzeitig in genau der Nacht, wo sie gerade versucht haben, dich zu pranken und dir deine Betthecke geklaut haben und du einfach den Rest deines Lebens sagst, ja Leute, das war's, da kann ich jetzt aufhören.
Ne, es war tatsächlich sehr unangenehm. Es war so, dass wir so im Zimmer waren in der Nacht, alle haben geschlafen und ich bin aufgestanden anscheinend aus meinem Bett, bin zur Tür rausgegangen, hab an der Nachbarstür angeklopft, an dem anderen Zimmer, jemand hat mir aufgemacht, ich hab dem anscheinend den grössten möglichen Schwachsinn der Welt erzählt, also wirklich nur uns zusammen, der dachte irgendwie, ich bin auf Drogen oder was, ich hab nur gesagt, ey, sorry, dass ich dich aufgeweckt hab, ich wollte dich nicht aufwecken, nachher kann ich mich noch erinnern, weil ich das auch geträumt hab gleichzeitig, dass ich gesagt habe, ey, ich wollte nicht aufwecken, tut mir leid, dann macht er die Tür zu und dann wollte ich, und dann genau, also die Tür zu meinem Zimmer war zu dem Punkt bereits zu und dann macht er die Tür zu und in dem Moment, in dem er die Tür zu macht, wache ich auf.
Das heißt, ich stehe in Unterwäsche vor verschlossener Tür in mein Zimmer.
Aber auch gut, dass sein Träumen, dass ich keine gute Gesellschaft, dass man einfach die Tür zumacht, weil man Angst vor dir hat. Ich habe mich am Tag danach mit dem unterhalten, da dachte ich, das war echt creepy, du hast echt wirklich nur Müll erzählt, also das war echt ganz anders als sonst. Ich habe einen Kumpel, der im Schlaf redet, und das ist ganz schön lustig, und dann plötzlich, das war auch mal irgendwann so, da habe ich den besucht und dann habe ich bei dem im Zimmer gepennt und dann plötzlich fing der an in der Nacht zu reden von Dingen, die ich ihm erzählt habe. Also er hat mir, und ich dachte, er hat nicht zugehört. Er hat seine eigenen Storys aus. Ja, er hat meine Geschichten erzählt und ich dachte, er hat nicht zugehört, weil ich den ganzen Tag labere und irgendeinen Schwachsinn labere und ich dachte, das interessiert ihn gar nicht. Und ich wusste auch, dass er sich für Fussball nicht interessiert, da habe ich ihm was von Fussball erzählt. Und dann wacht er nachts auf und hat mich geweckt dadurch, dass er aufgestanden ist.
Und dann ist er mir hingegangen und hat mir die Dinge vom Fussball erzählt.
Das ist einfach sehr lustig.
Wie gut. Ja, das ist mir schon klar.
Das habe ich dir gesagt.
Ja, das habe ich dir gesagt, du Arschloch.
Ja, wahrscheinlich muss der ganze Müll einfach raus. Jetzt gibt es mir...
Er sortiert einfach alles, was man gelernt hat, was nicht wichtig ist, einfach aus an dem Tag.
Ja.
Kann auch sein.
Ja, auf jeden Fall hatte ich Probleme, wieder zurück ins Zimmer zu kommen, bin dann zur Rezeption. Geschieht jetzt eigentlich viel besser und länger, aber ist auch egal. Macht kein Unterschied. Naja, ich hatte auch mal einen Freund, der auch ein bisschen crazy war im Schlaf. Aber das allerlustigste, da war ich noch nicht eingeschlafen und er schon, das allerlustigste war, er mitten in der Nacht richtet er sich einfach auf, so dass er im Bett sitzt, schaut mich an, gibt mir eine Thumbs-up und legt sich um und schläft. Und nicht nur so, okay, danke, cool, gutes Feedback, einfach vielen Dank. Es war nicht so lustig. Guter Tag, es war ein guter Tag und dann konntest du auch in Ruhe einschlafen. Ja, aber auch nicht von dir Zeit, einfach nur Thumbs-up, aber wirklich so energisch, so Bäm, Thumbs-up und und wieder einschlagen. War ja einfach gut. Das war, glaube ich, das beste Gespräch, das ich mit ihm jemals geführt habe. Mit irgendwem jemals gespürt hat. Ja, dann kommt niemand mehr. Nächstes Mal. Nächstes Mal. Ja, Traum ist ein ergiebiges Thema. Ja, schickt uns doch mal eure Träume. Ach, ich bin das immer so süß, wie du dann am Ende noch versuchst, die Community mit einzubeziehen. Ja, ja, und sagt uns mal, wo ihr Pfingsten gefeiert habt. Schreibt es bitte bei dem Tweet von Stefan Titzel. Schreibt es genau als Reply unter diesem Tweet, wo ihr Pfingsten gefeiert habt. Nee, er hat mich schon ganz verstanden. Das interessiert uns. Ihr habt mich schon richtig verstanden. Das war ein Gag. Nee, habt ihr nicht, du kannst dich im Nachhinein sagen, wenn niemand antwortet, kannst du nicht sagen, es war ein Gag, so funktioniert das nicht.
Doch, genau so funktionieren Gags.
Ne, ne, ne.
Nun gut, wir sind alle sehr müde, ich glaube, es war alles sehr, vielleicht war es einschläfernd, vielleicht war es sehr schläfrig tatsächlich.
Hört ihr das Podcast Ufo beim Einschlafen, würde uns auch mal interessieren. Ja, machen Sie, machen Sie.
Es ist auch so, dass ich jetzt mittlerweile Hörbücher für mich entdeckt habe, nachts, dann höre ich zum Einschlafen, höre ich dann immer Hörbücher und dann schlafe ich irgendwann, mache ich die irgendwann aus, weil ich pennen will, weil ich zu müde bin, um der Geschichte zu folgen. Und dann geht die Geschichte aber in meinem Kopf weiter, weil ich habe ja die ganze Zeit eben eine Stimme gehört, die geredet hat, und dann höre ich die weiter. Also die ist aus und dann will ich das wieder ausmachen, das Handy, und merke, es ist schon aus. Und das ist dann sehr gruselig, der Moment, wo man eine Stimme hört, die mit einem Reden, die eine Geschichte erzählt,
die plötzlich anfängt zu erzählen und einen zu beschimpfen
und dann denkt man, ja gut, ich mach's
vielleicht lieber aus und dann ist das Handy schon aus und es war
alles eingebildet, das ist sehr gruselig.
So, das war Podcast UFO Folge 21,
vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt, schaut auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder vorbei, wenn es heißt,
das Podcast UFO hebt ab!